uh so let's talk about SPF and FTX who
is uh Sam banquet freed can you tell a
story from the beginning as you
understand it yeah so Sam Beckman freed
is a kid who grew up sort of from a
position of huge privilege both his
parents our lawyers I believe both of
them were from Harvard he went to MIT
went to like or sorry backing up a bit
more he went to like this top Prep High
School then to MIT then he went to Jane
Street and after that he started a
trading firm and I think 2017 called
Alameda research with a few friends some
of them were from Jane Street some of
them worked at Google and they were sort
of the smartest Kids on the Block or
that's what everyone thought they made a
lot of their money on something called
the kimchi premium or at least this The
Story Goes which just to explain that uh
the price of Bitcoin in Korea was
substantially higher than in the rest of
the world and so you could Arbitrage
that by buying Bitcoin elsewhere and
selling it on a Korean exchange so they
made their money early doing kind of
smart trade like that they flip that
into Market making which they were
pretty early on that
um just providing liquidity to an
exchange and it's what it's a strategy
that is considered delta neutral which
means basically if you take kind of both
sides of the trade and you're making a
spread like a fee on that you make money
whether it goes up or down so in theory
there shouldn't be that much risk
associated with it so Alameda kind of
blew up because they would offer these
people you know people who are giving
out loans they'd say hey we'll give you
this really attractive rate of return
and we're doing strategies that
seemingly are low risk so we're a low
risk bet where these smart kids from
Jane Street and you can kind of trust us
to be this
smarter than everyone else kind of thing
uh around 2019 Sam started FTX which is
an exchange uh specifically it
specialized in derivatives so like
margins kind of more sophisticated
crypto products
and
it got in with binance early on so
binance actually has a prior
relationship to FTX which we'll explore
in a second because they're going to
play a role in ftx's collapse actually
Finance is the number one uh crypto
exchange and they're led by uh he's
called CZ on Twitter I don't want to
butcher his full name but um really
smart guy has played his hand really
well and built up a quite large exchange
and binance was funding a bunch of
different like startups so they funded
they helped invest into FTX early on
they invested 100 million so these guys
were kind of like teammates early on SPF
and CZ
and FTX quickly grew they got like
especially in 2020 20 21 they got a lot
of endorsements they got a lot of
credibility in the space
and eventually FTX actually bought out
binance they gave them two billion
dollars so pretty good investment for
for CZ in a couple years
um and now lead that up to 2022 what
happens Luna collapse three arrows
Capital collapse which if you don't know
there's just these kind of cataclysmic
events in crypto uh led by some pretty
risky Behavior whether Luna was a token
that promised really attractive returns
that were unsustainable ultimately and
it just kind of spiraled it did what's
called a stable coin death spiral which
we can talk about if we need to the
stable coin death spiral I can't wait
till that like actually enters the
Lexicon like a Wikipedia page on it like
uh economic students are learning it at
school yes it's like a chapter in a book
anyway
um I mean this is the reality of our
world this is a really big part of our
of the economic system is cryptocurrency
and stablecoin is part of that yeah it's
weird because on the one hand
cryptocurrency is supposed to somewhat
simplify or add transparency to the
financial markets the idea is for the
first time you don't have to wait for an
SEC filing from some corporate business
you can look at what they're doing on
chain right
um so that's good because a lot of big
financial problems are caused by lack of
transparency and lack of understanding
risk but ironically you get some people
creating these arbitrarily complicated
Financial products like algorithmic
stable coins which then introduce more
risk and blow everything up so anyways
uh three hours Capital blew up
and all of a sudden this crypto industry
which everyone thought was going to the
Moon Bitcoin to a hundred thousand is in
some trouble and FTX seems like the only
people who besides like binance who's
also really big and stable and coinbase
uh they seemed like they were doing fine
in fact they were bailing out companies
in the summer I don't know if you
remember that SBF was likened to like
Jamie Diamond who's the you know CEO of
Chase who like kind of was like the buck
stops here uh you know
I'm like the backstop right so SPF was
supporting the industry he was like the
stable guy so come to like around
October and November there's all this
talk about regulation everything's been
blowing up sbfs leading the charge on
regulation and CZ the CEO of Finance
gets word that maybe SBF is kind of like
cutting them out or making regulation
that would maybe impact his business
and uh he doesn't like that too much
they start kind of feuding a little bit
on Twitter so when it comes out a
coindesk report came out that
ftx's balance sheet wasn't looking that
good like it looked pretty weak they had
a lot of coins that in theory had value
if you looked at their market price but
for a variety of reasons if you tried to
sell them they'd collapse in value so
it's sort of like this thing a house
built on Sand and a friend of mine on
Twitter he goes by Dirty Bubble media he
released a report and he basically said
I think these uh these guys are
insolvent well CZ saw that and he
retweeted it and started adding fuel to
the fire of like the speculation because
up till this point everyone thought FTX
is super safe super secure there's no
reason to not keep your money there Tom
Brady keeps his money there whatever
and CZ kind of feel adds fuel to the
fire by saying not only am I retweeting
this adding kind of like validity to
this speculation but also I'm going to
take the ftt that I got which part of
their balance sheet was this ftt token
which is ftx's like proprietary token
and Alameda and FTX control a lot of it
they were using this token to basically
be a large amount of collateral for
their whole balance sheet so it
accounted for this huge amount of their
value and the CEO of binance had a huge
chunk of it as well and he said I'm
going to sell all of it and the I the
fuel that that introduced to the market
is if he sells all this ftt and this ftt
is underwriting a lot of the value of
FTX does fdt's almost approximate like
uh similar things if you were to buy a
stock in a public company is that kind
of like a stock in FTX it sort of was
this proxy because what FTX was
committed to doing was sort of like
buying back ftt tokens they would do
this thing called the buy and burn I
think there was some amount of sharing
in the revenue fees of FTX it was kind
of this convoluted thing in my opinion
the exact value of ftt was speculative
from the beginning and it was clear that
it was very tied to the performance of
FTX which is important because we'll get
to later FTX sort of built their whole
scaffold on ftt which meant that this
scaffold was very wobbly because if FTX
loses a little bit of confidence then
your value goes down when your value
goes down you lose more confidence and
this goes down so it was kind of like
this thing that this flywheel that when
it was going well you got huge amounts
of growth when it's going bad you get a
uh exchange death spiral so to speak
actually this structure it's a pretty
non-standard structure did The
Architects of its initial design
anticipate the wobbliness of the whole
system so putting fraud and all those
things that happen later aside do you
think it was difficult to anticipate
this kind of FDT FTX elemented research
weird dynamic no because I think
sophisticated Traders always think in
terms of diversification and correlation
so if you're trying to the way to think
about risk in investing is like if I
invest in
you Lex Friedman and then I also invest
in some product you produce those those
the performance of those two things will
be pretty correlated so whether I invest
in you or I invest in this product that
you like are completely behind
I'm not de-risking I'm basically
counting all on you doing well right and
if you do bad my investments do very bad
so if I'm trying to build a stable thing
I shouldn't put all my eggs in The Lex
Friedman basket unless I'm positive that
you're going to do well right and these
people as your financial advisor I would
definitely recommend you do not put all
your eggs in this basket right and so
you can think about it like if I know
that these people were trained to think
like this and so the idea that you could
start this exchange you're worth
billions of dollars and you underwrite
your whole system by betting putting
most of it on your own token is is
insane and what and what's crazy is
we'll later find out that they were
basically taking customer assets which
were real things like Bitcoin and
ethereum with
with risks that were not so correlated
to FDX and they were swapping them out
they were using to go go basically
gamble those and putting ftt in its
place as quote value so they were
increasing the risk of the system in
order to bet big with the idea that if
they bet big in one we'd all be singing
their praises if we bet big and law if
they bet big and lost
I don't know if they had a plan but I
think they were I think they were being
extremely risky and there's no way to
avoid their knowledge of That So when
you say customer assets is I come to
this crypto exchange I have Bitcoin or
some other cryptocurrency and this is a
a thing that has
pretty stable value over time I mean
yeah right that's crypto relative
relatively so and I'm going to store it
on this crypto exchange and that that's
the whole point this is uh
so this thing to the degree that crypto
holds value
is supposed to continue holding value
there's not there's not supposed to be
an extra risk inserted into the thing
right and FTX was pretty clear from the
beginning that they wouldn't invest your
assets and anything else they wouldn't
do anything else with it they wouldn't
trade it
that's what made FTX so such like a
horror story for investor confidence is
basically they made every signal that
they would not do anything nefarious
with your tokens they would just put
them to the side put them in a separate
account that they don't have access to
and they just kind of wait there until
the day that you're ready to withdraw
them that's explicitly what they told
their customers so going back to the
story a little bit CZ then says hey I'm
selling this token that underwrites the
value of FTX there's a total panic
SPF during this time makes set says
several lies such as FTX assets are fine
we have enough money to cover all
withdrawals
um and a day later he basically admits
that that wasn't the case they don't
have the money they're shutting down and
then a few days later after that they
declared bankruptcy
there's I should be clear there's
Alameda research FTX International and
FTX us which is the U.S side of things
these are three different entities
all of them are on bankruptcy and it's
not clear to the extent that they were
co-mingling funds but it's clear that
they were co-mingling funds to some
extent so they kind of worked taking
from each other and that is where the
fraud happens right because if going
back to our earlier analogy if you're
supposed to set funds aside and I find
out you were using it to go make all
these Arbitrage trades or do Market
making or all these activities you were
known for for your like hedge fund
trading firm thing that's a huge problem
because you he basically lied about this
and especially when he's saying
explicitly that we have these things we
have these funds and these things turn
out to be lies well again the question
of fraud comes in and it's just like
there's no way he didn't know so the
obvious question might be well why isn't
he locked up why why is he running
around and it's because
um
really his story is that he didn't know
any of it he found out that they had to
steal mana's position he would say he
was totally disconnected from what
Alameda was doing he had no idea that
they had such a large margin position
that they had an accounting Quirk and
that accounting Quirk hit eight billion
dollars from um from
his View and so when he was saying that
they had money to cover it he was saying
that truthfully to the best of his
ability and he just was so distracted at
the time that he made a series of
increasingly embarrassing mistakes and
now he owes it to the people to write
those wrongs by publicly making this
huge apology tour so you might have seen
him on I mean he's been talking to
nearly everyone
um
about basically how he's just didn't
know what he's doing he's the stupidest
man alive uh so what what what are some
interesting things you've learned from
those interviews
I think I've appreciated why you don't
talk in that position uh most people
wouldn't talk most people would listen
to their legal counsel and and not talk
I do not think he's any lawyer where
their salt would tell him to talk
because right now I think the danger of
what he's doing is he's locking himself
into a story of how things happened and
I don't think that story is going to
hold up in the coming months because I
think it's impossible from The Insider
conversations I've had with Alameda
research employees with FTX employees
it's impossible to square what they are
telling me with no like incentive to lie
with what SBF is telling me with every
incentive to lie which is fundamentally
that he didn't know they were
co-mingling funds he didn't know they
were gambling with customer money and it
was basically this huge mistake and it's
alameda's fault but he wasn't involved
in Alameda a company he owned so like uh
compassionate but heart hitting gangster
that you are recently very recently you
interact with SPF on uh I like how you
adjust uh the suspenders as you're
saying this
you interact on Twitter spaces uh with
SPF
and uh really put his feet to the fire
uh with some hard-hitting questions what
did you ask them what did you learn from
that interaction sure I should say first
this was not a willing interaction I
mean I thought that was kind of the
funny part of it because I've been
asking him for an interview for a while
he's been giving interviews to nearly
everyone who wants one big channels
small channels
um he didn't give me one but I managed
to get some by sneaking up on some
Twitter spaces and dming the people and
like being like hey can I come up so I
didn't get him to ask everything that I
wanted because he like would leave
sometimes uh you know after I asked some
of the questions but really what I asked
was about this 8 billion and zooming in
on the improbability of his lack of
knowledge
um it's sort of like if you if you run a
company and you know the insides and
outs and you're the top of your field
top top in class
and all of a sudden it all goes busting
you say I had no idea how any of this
worked yeah I didn't I didn't know it's
like the guy who runs Whataburger saying
I didn't know where we sourced our beef
I didn't know where we that's a Texas
example actually thank you I appreciate
it uh let's let's take it like worldwide
Walmart like I didn't know we used
Chinese manufacturers it's like that's
impossible to become Walmart you have to
know how like how your supply chain
works you have to know even if you're at
a high level you know how this stuff
works can I do a hard turn on that and
go sure as one must to Hitler uh
Hitler's writing is not on any of the
documents around as far as I know uh on
the final solution so in in some crazy
world you could theoretically say I knew
I didn't know anything about death camps
uh so there's this plausible deniability
in theory so that's but that most people
would look at that and say uh it's very
unlikely you don't know especially if
all the Insiders are coming out and
saying no no of course he knew he was
directing us from the top I mean um what
was clear what's interesting about the
structure and like I love the knitting
yeah we're back to SPF we went to his
sorry now we're back I wanted to turn us
as fast as possible away from it
um I yeah I so the Insiders in what
Almer Alameda research what was
interesting is that there was this sort
of one-way window going on between
Alameda and FTX where FTX employees
didn't know a lot of what was going on
Alameda insiders and I would say by
Design knew almost everything that was
going on at FTX
um and so I think that was really
interesting from the perspective of a
lot of the so-called like what you could
what he's trying to ascribe to as like
failures or mistakes or ignorance and
negligence when looked at closely are
much more designed and they sort of
don't arise spontaneously because like
let's say so there's this thing in
banking and like trading where if I run
a bank and you run like a trading firm
we need to have informational walls
between us because there's huge
conflicts of interest that can arise
right so the negligent argument might be
that like oh we just didn't know we're
sort of these dumb kids in the Bahamas
so we share it information equally
but when you see a one-way wall that
starts to look a lot different right if
I have a back-end source of looking at
or sorry you're the trading firm so you
have a back-end way to look at all my
accounts and I have no idea that you're
doing that that all of a sudden looks
like a much more designed thing when it
would be plausible let's say going to to
use another another analogy too if
you're saying look I co-mingled funds
because I was so bad at corporate
structures you would expect those
companies to have a very simple
corporate structure because you didn't
know what you're doing right but what we
see with FTX and Alameda is they had
something like 50 companies and
subsidiaries and this Inc impossibly
complicated web of corporate activity
you don't get there by accident you
don't wake up and go oh I designed like
this watch that ticked a very specific
way but it was all accidental if you
really didn't know what you were doing
you'd end up with a simple structure so
even just like from a fundamental
perspective what SPF was doing and like
the activities they were engaging in
were so complicated and purposely
designed to obfuscate what they were
doing it's impossible to subscribe to
the negligence argument and I want to
quickly say too like I don't think a lot
of people have honed in on this there
was insider trading going on
From alameda's perspective where
they would know what coins FTX was going
to list on their exchange there's a
famous effect where let's say you're
this legitimate exchange you list a coin
the price spikes
insiders told me it was a regular
practice for Alameda insiders to know
that FTX was going to list a coin and as
a company buy up that coin so they could
sell it after it listed and they made
millions of dollars how do you do that
accidentally yeah and that's that's
illegal totally illegal so that's
illegal from like and if an individual
does it it's illegal it's fraud what if
a company is systematically doing it and
you can't tell me that FTX
or somewhat at FTX wasn't feeding that
information about to Alameda or somehow
giving them keys to know that and that
would happen at the highest level it
would happen at SPS level and this is
why his arguments of I was dumb I was
naive I was sort of ignorant or so
Preposterous because he's dumb and
ignorant the second it becomes criminal
to be smart and sophisticated right
but then also coming out and talking
about it which is uh
it's a bizarre move it's a bizarre and
almost a dark move uh can you tell the
story of the 8 billion you mentioned 8
billion what's the 8 billion what's the
missing eight billion yeah so it's
really interesting because it's sort of
like wire fraud you sort of he's sort of
copping to like smaller crimes to avoid
the big crime the big crime is you knew
everything and you were behind it right
the smaller crimes are like a little
wire fraud here little wire fraud there
so what the 8 billion is is that FTX
didn't always have banking it's hard to
get banking as a crypto exchange there's
all these questions of like where's the
money coming from is it coming from
money launder so
for a variety of reasons it's always
been hard for exchanges to get bank
accounts so before when FTX was just
getting started they didn't have a bank
account so how do you put money on FTX
well they would have you wire your money
to their trading firm their wiring
instructions would go to their trading
firm it's easier to get banking as a
trading firm so you'd put your money
with the trading firm and then they'd
credit you the money on FTX
okay first of all this is a whole
circumvention of all these banking
guidelines and regulations
that's the first like thing that I think
is legal but
basically what SBF argued is that there
was an accounting glitch error problem
where when you'd send money to Alameda
even though they'd credit you on FTX
they wouldn't Safeguard your deposits
like your deposits would go into what he
called a stub account which is just like
some account that's not very well
labeled
um kind of like a placeholder account
and
he didn't realize that those were
alameda's funds or they were playing
with those funds and that they basically
should have safeguarded that for
customers that's his explanation it's
Preposterous because it's eight billion
dollars but anyways
um just poor labeling of accounts of an
8 billion dollar account I mean it's a
billion between a billion this is like
doing this all the time this is the
craziest thing like he was he was
talking to me and at one point in the
conversation he's like yeah I didn't
have precise not because he said I
didn't have knowledge of alameda's
accounts and I said well Forbes a month
ago was getting detailed accounting of
Alameda and he goes oh that wasn't
detailed accounting I just knew I was
right within 10 billion or so
what is that error margin 10 billion
dollars for a company that is arguably
never worth more than 100 million yeah
that probably never never even worth
more than 50 billion your error margin
is 10 billion you have to be this is a
guy who is sending around
statements that like there was no risk
involved and you're telling me he had a
error margin of 10 billion dollars that
is the difference between like a healthy
company and a company so deep underwater
you're going to jail so it you have to
believe that he is impossibly stupid and
square that with the sophistication that
he brought to the table it's an I think
it's an impossible argument I I don't
even think it's do you think he is
incompetent insane or evil
if you were to bet
money on each of those incompetent
insane or evil insane meaning he's lying
to everyone but also to himself
uh which you could which is a little bit
different than incompetence he's not
incompetent
so the I think he's some combination of
insane and evil but it's impossible to
know unless we know deep inside his
heart how self
like deluded he is versus a calculated
strategy and I think if you look at SBF
he's such a I think he's a fascinating
individual just I mean you know he's a
horrible human being let's start there
but he's also somewhat
um
interesting from a psychology
perspective because he's very open about
the fact that he understands image and
he understands how to cultivate image
the importance of image so well that I
think a lot of people even though
they've talked about it aren't
emphasizing that enough
when interacting with him this is a man
whose entire history is about
cultivating the right opinions at the
right time to achieve the right effect
why do you think he would suddenly
change that approach when he has all the
more reason to cultivate an image so he
is
extremely good naturally or uh I don't
know if he's good but he's like he's a
hyper aware it was deliberate in
cultivating a Public Image and
controlling the Public Image you you
know about the like Democrat donations
like he he knew to donate to the right
people 40 million dollars he says on a
call that we released with Tiffany Fong
he says on a call that he donated the
same amount to Republicans there's
speculation on whether this is true
because he's a liar whatever so caveat
there but he said he donated to
Republicans the same amount but he
donated dark because he knew that most
journalists are liberal and they would
kind of hold that against him so he
wanted all the all the sides to be on in
his favor in his pocket while
simultaneously understanding the entire
media landscape and playing them like a
fiddle by cultivating this image of I'm
this Progressive woke billionaire who
wants to give it all away do everything
for charity I drive a Corolla while
living in a million dollar Penthouse
multi-million
um but but that was sort of the angle he
he understood so well how to play the
media and um
I do I think he underestimated when he
did this how much people would put him
under a deeper microscope and I don't
think he has achieved the same level of
success in cultivating this new image
because I think people are so skeptical
now no one's buying it but I think he
he's trying it he's doing it to the best
but it has work leading up to this
particular wobbly situation so before
that was in their public perception of
him being
a Force for good a financial 100 yeah
somebody from Sequoia Capital you know
wrote this glowing review that he's
going to be the world's first
trillionaire there's so many pieces done
on he's the most generous billionaire in
the world that um he was sort of like
the Steel Man of you know it's possible
to make tons of money this is like the
effect of altruism movement make as much
money as you can as fast as you can and
give it all away and he was sort of like
the the poster child for that and he did
give some of it away and got a lot of
press for it and I think that was kind
of by Design I want to address a real
quick Point yes a lot of people have
said that like binance played a role and
while they catalyzed this
insolvency
is a problem that will eventually
manifest either way so I don't put any
blame on CZ for basically causing this
meltdown the the underlying Foundation
was unstable and it was going to fall
apart at the next push I mean he just
happened to be the final kind of like
uh I don't know the straw that broke the
camel's back yeah the Catalyst are
revealed yeah but he's like I don't I
don't think he's culpable for ftx's like
malfeasance and how they handle accounts
if that makes sense so what what role
did they play could they have helped
alleviate some of the pain of uh
uh investors of people that held funds
there yeah I mean
probably uh I don't know I I would see
some kind of weird obligation like with
the 2 billion they made on FTX remember
they got 2 billion some of it in cash
some of it in some of it in FDT token so
I don't know how much actual cash they
have from that deal but they have
billions from the success of what seems
to be a fraud seems to have been a fraud
from early on they had the back door as
early as 20 early 2020 from what I can
tell so the the back door between FTX
and um
uh do you think CZ saw through who SPF
is
what is he's doing
no I think
I think CZ is like he's a shark I think
he's he's good at building a big
business
um like a good I don't go back truck I
don't know I don't know I think sharks
just eat I mean I I don't I don't know I
think uh my relationship with Shaw has
like Finding Nemo there's a shark in
that sure I don't know I think like Jeff
Bezos is a shark okay so whether you
people have loaded connotations of like
how they feel about Jeff Bezos I mean I
I would say like I think CZ is a
ruthless businessman
I think these qualities calculated he's
very
um
deliberate and
I think uh what he should do in this
position is forfeit the funds that he
profited from that investment because
largely I think it was
um it's owed to the customers there's so
much hurting out there so I think I
think they could do a lot of good around
that
um I don't know if they will because I
don't know if he sees it in his best
interest I think that's probably how
he's thinking but yeah I I think they
could have helped or they could still
help there who do you think suffered the
most from this so far
the little account holders this is
always true so one of the big
Temptations with fraud I've covered a
lot of scams frauds is everyone looks at
the big number everyone that's the
headline billions of dollars the top 50
creditors or whatever one thinks that
first
uh but quickly when you dig down you
realize that most people who lost 10
million dollars I mean I'm sure that's
terrible for them I wish them to get
their money back but uh it's usually the
people with like 50 000 or less that are
most impacted usually they do not have
the money to spare usually they're not
Diversified in a sophisticated way
um so I think it's those people I think
it's the small account holders that I
feel the worst for and unfortunately
they often get the least press time or
air time that's a really difficult truth
of this is that especially in the
culture of cryptocurrency there's a lot
of young people who are not Diversified
they're basically all in on a particular
crypto
and it just breaks my heart to think
that there's somebody with fifty
thousand or thirty thousand or Twenty
Thousand but the point is that money
is everything they own
right and now
now what their life is basically
destroyed
like you know imagine your 18 19 20 21
years old
you saved up you've been working you
saved up
and this is this is it this is basically
destroying a life
what's so brutal about this is that this
all comes on the back the entire crypto
Market comes on the back of
comes from the deep distrust of
traditional Finance right yeah 2008
everybody lost trust in the banking
systems and they lost trust that if
those banking systems acted in a corrupt
way that they would receive the Justice
it turned out that the banks received
favorable treatment people didn't so
people
lost faith in the the structure of our
financial system in a way that is we're
still feeling the reverberations of it
and so when crypto came along it was
like kind of this way to reinvent the
wheel reinvent the world for the the
like sort of lowly and the like less
powerful and kind of level the playing
field so it's so sad about events like
this is you see that fundamentally a lot
of the the power structures are the same
where the people at the top uh face
little repercussions for what they do
the people at the bottom are still
getting screwed the people at the bottom
are still getting lied to and law
enforcement is way behind the ball
do you think that's really uh
damaged people trust in cryptocurrency
for sure way bigger than uh Luna way
bigger than three hours Capital it's
because of who SBF was it's not just the
dollar figure behind it it's because he
wooed so many of our media Elites who
should have been calling him out or at
least investigating him and not rubber
stamping him
it's an indictment of our financial
system or even our most sophisticated
people in Blackrock in Sequoia who
didn't see this coming who also rubber
stamped him
um and you just wonder like if you can't
trust the top people in crypto who are
supposedly the good guys the guys saving
crypto month just a month ago or two
months ago he was the guy on Capitol
Hill that was talking to Gary Gensler to
all the top people in Washington he was
orchestrating the regulation of crypto
if that guy is a complete fraudster liar
psychopath and nobody knew it until it
was too late what does that mean about
the system itself that we're building so
you are one of not the best
like fraudster
investigators in the world did you sense
did you uh was this on your radar at all
SPF in the over the past couple years
were any red flags going off for you yes
so funny enough like one of my videos
from six months ago or so blew up
because um
I got to give a lot of credit to Matt
Levine of Bloomberg great journalist
great Finance journalist and I want to
say when I like talk about media Elite
there are people doing great work in
these mainstream institutions it's not a
monolith just like Independent Media
isn't all doing great work and all the
corporate media is bad or whatever
there's like these overarching
narratives that I don't subscribe to so
Matt Levine's great journalist he he
didn't interview with SPF where
he got Sam to basically describe a lot
of what was going on in D5 but at kind
of a larger philosophy around crypto and
he described a Ponzi scheme where he
just described this black box it does
nothing but if we ascribe it value then
we can create more value and more value
and more value and it kind of was this
ridiculous description of a Ponzi scheme
but there was no moral judgment on it it
was like oh yeah this is great we can
make a lot of money from this and Matt
is like well it sounds like you're in
the Ponzi business and business is good
I made a video about that I said this is
ridiculous this is absurd whatever it's
obscene
but
um
I didn't explicitly call SBF a fraud
there
and I think if if I'm being I think I
saw some of it but like many people I
think a lot of us were kind of like
I think a lot of us missed how wrong
everyone could be at the same time
I did notice leading up to the crash
what was happening and I and I caught it
out a day a day or a day and a half
before it happened because I saw my
friends post a dirty bubble media and
this was the first real look into the
heart of their finances because they're
this black box you just kind of had to
evaluate them
without knowing much
and once we got a peek under the hood of
what their finances were
I realized oh my gosh these guys might
be completely insolvent so I made a
tweet about it I hope some people saw it
and got their money out
um
but pretty quickly after that I caught
The Narrative of what was really going
on at Alameda
that it was basically this Ponzi scheme
that they had built do you ever sit like
Batman in The Dark since he fight crime
and wonder like sad just staring into
the darkness and thinking I should have
caught this earlier
yeah I think in your in your uh 10
billion dollars to 10 million dollars 10
million dollars we're working our way
there
um sure like it's never enough It's
never enough like you always could be
catching stuff sooner you always could
be doing more I mean the fascinating
thing you said is that
one of the lessons here is that a large
number of people influential smart
people could all be wrong at the same
time in terms of their evaluation of SBF
this is this is one thing that I don't
understand too is like I think it's one
thing to not see something
I think it's another thing to like
rubber stamp or explicitly endorse I
feel like
a lot of people didn't look too close at
SPF because I think a lot of the warning
signs were there but my feeling is if
you're a sequoia if you're a black rock
wouldn't you do that due diligence I
mean like yeah like before just
endorsing something especially in the
crypto space this is just why I don't do
any deals in the crypto space ever
because it's impossible to know which
ones are going to be the like big hits
or the big frauds or you know whatever
um but if you're gonna make that bet if
you're going to make that play you would
think
that you would do all the research in
the world and you would get
sophisticated looks at their liabilities
at how they were structured all that
stuff and that is the most shocking part
is not that you know people missed it
because you can miss fraud but that
there were so much so many glowing
endorsements like this guy is not going
to be that thing we explicitly endorse
him I saw a Fortune Magazine he was
called the next Warren Buffett it's just
crazy do you think it's possible to have
enough like Tom Brady
uh endorsements that you don't really
investigate so like yes that there's a
kind of momentum like societal social
momentum I think that's the problem I
actually think that's hugely a blind
like a a blind spot of our society as we
have all these heuristics that can be
points of failure where like a rule of
thumb is if you go to an Ivy League well
you must be smart right a rule of thumb
is if you're both your parents are
Harvard lawyers you must not you must
know the law you must like kind of be
sophisticated the rule of thumb is if
you're running a billion dollar exchange
you must be somehow somewhat ethical
right and all of these heuristics can
lead to Giant blind spots where you kind
of just go oh we'll check like I don't
really it's a lot of energy to look into
people and if enough of those rules of
thumb are met we just kind of check them
off and put them through the system so
uh yeah it's been hugely exposing for
sort of like our blind spot and you
don't know maybe how to look at for
example there's a few assumptions now
there's a lot of people are very
skeptical of institutions of government
and so on but for um perhaps too much so
I agree but for some part of history
there was a too much faith in government
yeah and so
um right now I think there's faith in
certain large companies there's distrust
in certain ones and Trust in others like
people seem to distrust Facebook
extremely skeptical Facebook but they
trust I think Google with their data I
think they trust apple with their data
sure much much more so like search
people don't seem to be you Google
search like huh I'm just gonna I'm gonna
throw it in there have you ever looked
at your Google search history your
Google search history has got to be some
of the darkest things oh I don't think
I've ever looked at my Google search
history you should be careful with uh
like
browser hygiene and uh stuff like that
because I think it's
well Google search history unless you
explicitly delete is there I recommend
you look at it it's fascinating look
because it goes back to the first days
of you using Google search history fun
fact actually about that no no I I I am
I am aware of that
um I just mean for like certain
sensitive topics where like I'm
investigating some fraud and I go sign
into their website right log in I won't
use like a traditional browser I'll use
a VPN and I'll like put it on like Brave
or something like that you log in you
create an account is Lex Friedman yeah
exactly exactly exactly uh you mentioned
effective altruism yes you know SPF has
been associated with this effective
altruism which made me look twice at EA
sure and see like wait
um
ID what's what's going on here
uh is this was this used by SBF to give
himself a good Public Image or is there
something about effective altruism that
makes it easy to misuse by bad people
what do you think yeah it's interesting
he could have endorsed a wide range of
philosophies and I guess you just have
to wonder
are all those would those philosophies
also be tainted if
um he had gone bad I guess effective
altruism is sort of unique because he
used it as part of his brand it wasn't
like he was he described himself as a
consequentialist and like that ended up
mattering it was like he described
himself as an effective altruist and he
used that part of the brand to lift
himself up I guess that's why it's
getting so much scrutiny
um I think the merits of it should speak
for themselves I mean I don't personally
I'm not personally an effective altruist
um I personally am motivated by giving
in part emotionally and for some reason
that I can't exactly describe I think
that's somewhat important I don't think
you should detach giving from some
personal connection I I find trouble
with that
and and like I said it's for reasons I
Can't Describe because effective
altruism is sort of the most logical
Ivory Tower position you could possibly
take it's like strip all Humanity away
from giving let's treat it like a
business and how many people can we
serve through the McDonald's line of
charity for like the dollar right
um I just personally don't resonate with
that but I don't think the entire
movement is like indicted because of it
typically most people who care about
giving and charity
on the whole are nice people and are so
I can't speak for the whole movement I
certainly don't think SBF indicts the
whole movement even though I personally
don't subscribe to it yeah that it made
me pause reflect and step back like um
about the movement and about anything
that has a strong ideology so if there's
anything in your life that's a strong
set of ideas behind it be careful yeah I
mean look I kind of feel like what it
teaches me and what I kind of think
about when I think about systems is that
no system saves you from the individual
no system saves you from the individual
their intentions their their lust for
power or greed I mean I think one of the
great ideas
is the decentralization of power and
like this is why
I think democracies are so great is
because they decentralize power across a
wide range of like interests and groups
and that being an effective way to kind
of try as best as you can to spread out
the impact of one individual because one
bad individual can do a lot of harm as I
mean clearly as seen here but um no I
don't think it has anything to do with
ideology because it's not like being an
effective altruist made Sam bankman free
to fraud he was a fraud who happened to
be an effective Walter well this makes
sense so there is something about yes no
system protects you from an individual
but some system
enable or service a better Catalyst than
others for uh for the worst aspects of
human nature so for example communist
ideology I don't know if it's the
ideology or its implementation in this
in the in the 20th century it seemed
like such a sexy and powerful and viral
ideology that it somehow allows the evil
bad people to like sneak into the very
top and so like that's what I mean about
certain ideas and sound so nice
that allow you like the the lower
classes the workers the people that do
all the work they should have power they
they have been screwed over for far too
long they need to take power back that
sounds like a really powerful idea and
then it just seems like with those
powerful ideas
evil people sneak in to the top and
start to abuse that power yeah I think
I mean I don't have a lot of probably
big brain political takes but what I can
say is that you can never get away from
both the system and the individual
mattering for sure some systems
incentivize some behaviors in certain
ways but some people will take that and
go okay all we need to do is design the
perfect system and then these
individuals will act completely
rationally or responsibly in accordance
to what our incentives say that's not
true you could also say all we have to
do is focus on the individual and all we
have to do is just create a society
which raises very well-adjusted people
and then we can throw them into any
system with any incentives and they will
act like responsibly ethically morally
and I also don't think that's true so
incentives are real but also
the individual ultimately plays a large
role too so yeah I don't know I come
down sort of in the middle there and
some of that is just accidents of
History to which individuals finds which
system you know uh become the face of
that yeah with FDX versus uh coinbase
versus binance which individual would
which kinds of ideas and uh life story
come to power because that matters it's
kind of fascinating that history turns
on these small little events done by
small little individuals that uh you
know Hitler's a failed artist or you
have FDR or you have uh all these
different characters that do good or do
evil onto the world and it's like single
individuals and they have a life story
and it could have turned out completely
different
it's I mean it's the flap of the
butterfly wings so yeah you're right it
we should be skeptical as attributing
too much to the system or the individual
it's all like a Beautiful Mess
the last Friedman podcast
that's like that was like a Lex line
I've heard I've I've heard quite a few
episodes and that's like such a relaxed
line it's a beautiful map all right
beautifully said all right sorry I'm a
fan of the show oh okay all right I love
you too uh all right
can you think of possible trajectories
how this
FTX SPF Saga ends uh and which one do
you hope for do you hope that SBF goes
to jail
and that's the individual and in terms
of the investors and the customers what
do you hope happens and what do you
think are the possible things that can
happen
so hey yeah I definitely think SPF
should go to jail
um for nothing else for a semblance of
Justice the facsimile of Justice to
occur for all the investors
um I also think there are people
probably several steps down the chain
that probably knew at least Caroline
Ellison you can have questions about
sort of their you know Dan Friedberg who
I'd love to talk about as well
um there were a lot of people in that
room who I think knew I think we do so
much of like the one guy is All To Blame
let's throw everything at him when
clearly this was a company-wide issue so
everyone who knew I think should face
the same punishment which I think should
be jail for all of those people
um
in part to send a signal to anybody that
tries this kind of stuff in the future
yeah absolutely I mean one of the big
things that you saw like okay take a
microcosm of all of this action and just
look at like the influencer space right
there's a ton of deals that were done
that I've covered Ad nauseam about
influencer finds out they can make a lot
of money selling a crypto coin the first
thing they wonder is am I going to get
caught
if I do this is there a consequence and
if the answer is no then it's a pretty
easy decision as long as you don't like
have any moral scriptures about it which
apparently none of them did or a lot of
them did and I should say
so
as soon as somebody steps in and
regulates that math changes and all of a
sudden there's a self-interest reason to
not go do the bad thing so for example
and I can give a concrete example of
this
there was a nft the first ever nft sort
of like
official indictment or the doj released
this press release that they're charging
these guys who ran a nft project that
they didn't follow through on their
promises they made all these promises
lied and then ran away with the money
first ever consequence for anyone in the
nft space that day that that press
release came out I saw several nft
um projects come back to life from the
dead
why because all those Founders are
freaking out and they realized we
scammed people we have to go at least
make make it look like we're doing the
right thing right even just so that's on
the optic side but there's also tons of
people who now go oh the basically law
enforcement is on the scene we can't do
the same thing so there is a very
pragmatic reason to for this punishment
it's very much just because people work
it into their math of should I commit
fraud and the last several years have
been very
um sort of has been like a little bit of
a nihilistic landscape where no one was
getting punished and so there's this
question of you're almost an idiot if
you didn't take the deals
um so I think it's really important
extremely important for kind of law
enforcement to play a role regulation to
play a role to make it harder to commit
those crimes and if you commit those
crimes there's actual real world
punishment for it
to your point about like what's going to
happen to the investors I think that was
kind of your question
it's tough because the if the money's
not there the money's not there I mean
there's going to be the guy they got the
Best in Class guy it's the guy who ran
the dissolving of Enron so I mean I
can't imagine someone better equipped to
run a complicated corporate fraud like
dissolution but
yeah it's it's tough because everyone's
going to get probably I don't know 10
cents on the dollar maybe less I wonder
if there's a way to do a progressive
redistribution of funds so I just I'm
just really worried about the pain that
small investors feel I think yeah I
think um there's a lot of thought around
that I forget if
if they actually do do this I mean I
know there's a lot of law about like you
can't treat
creditors differently you have to treat
them all the same so I think it'll be
some kind of proportional payback it's
certainly not going to be that the guys
at the top get you know a significant
amount of their money back and the rest
get nothing unfortunately I think
there's such a
small amount of assets that back this
whole thing in the end and that value is
actually declining every day because it
was inextricably tied to fsbf it was
like the ftt tokens which now what are
those worth the serum tokens that was
his project or the project they made
what is that worth basically nothing so
you know it's a very it's a hard
situation and you know there's a bigger
ethical concern which is FTX us
it's unclear how backed it was but it
was clearly more backed than FTX
International
do you take all that money and throw it
into a big pot and give people money
back or do you give the US people back
their amount of money which is probably
going to be significantly more and leave
everyone internationally out in the cold
and to add to that ethical issue let's
say you're a liquidator and you're
us-based
there's a tremendous question like legal
questions about you know how do you
ethically do that it's not it's not
clear there's a tremendous incentive to
just favor the U.S people over everyone
else because it's our country America
whatever but um I don't know if that's
necessarily Fair it's it's really hard
it's like it's impossible and some uh I
forget where you said this but one of
the I mean it probably uh permeates a
lot of the investigations you do which
is this idea that it's really sad that
the middle class in most situations like
this get [ __ ] over so the the IRS I'll
go after the middle class they'll go
after the rich is basically everyone who
doesn't have a lot of Leverage in terms
of lawyers money get [ __ ] over
yes and then they're the ones like it's
always the rich and Powerful who get the
favorable treatment as it like a
microcosm of this funny story so
one of the big criticisms of crypto and
I think rightly so is the
irreversibility of the transaction so if
I accidentally send a transaction
somewhere it's gone right yeah so
crypto.com accidentally sent a lady 10
million dollars
and now they want the money back and
they're suing her but the funny thing is
is if you are on crypto.com and you send
let's say I accidentally send you money
and I come knocking on your door it
looks I didn't mean to send you you know
like uh a thousand dollars I need my
money back
or if I go to crypto.com and I said hey
I sent that to the wrong person can you
reverse it they'll say screw off no way
if I go to court they'll kill me in
court because they're going to go look
this is how the blockchain works but
then they do it they do the exact same
thing they send this lady 10 million
dollars they're suing or no they're
going to win now it's now what's in
court is not whether they get the money
back it's should she be liable for theft
I believe so
and that's in just another case of
the same rules apply differently to
different people whether you have the
money to back you or not it's a very sad
thing and that's why I think people like
you need
journalists fighting for
the little person
we really need it and it's kind of like
this unfortunate thing where that's the
most risky thing to do like legally you
should not be doing that but
um I think it's important to do it's the
ethical thing it's the right thing to do
uh what do you think about influencers
and celebrities that supported FTX and
SBF do they should they be punished yeah
I think I think they should take a huge
reputational hit I mean I think they
should be embarrassed I think they
should be ashamed of themselves but it
was really hard to know sorry to
interrupt for them to know like for
example I think about this a lot yeah
it's like
who do I
because I don't investigate you know
like uh sponsored by athletic greens
okay it's a nutritional drink should I
investigate them deeply I don't I don't
know you just kind of use reputational
like it seems to work for me should I
like I think I think it really depends
on I think your credibility hit will
depend on what domain you're an expert
in if you're sponsored by a robotics
company
and you're an expert in robotics if that
company turns out to be a disaster and
fraud then you should have looked more
deeply we're talking mostly about like I
hold Tom Brady a lot less accountable
than financial advisors Financial
influencers because that is their world
of expertise and you treat their Rec
recommendation differently
proportionally to what you think their
expertise is so in some ways I don't
actually think Tom Brady I'm sure you
reached a lot of people I personally
didn't feel at all moved by his
recommendation because you know it's
just money
but when you hear somebody who should be
an expert in that thing
endorse a product in that space you hold
that opinion to a higher standard and
when they're completely
cataclysmically wrong it's going to be a
different level of accountability and I
think rightfully so when um Jim Cramer
in was saying bear Stearns is fine he
made that terrible call and bear with
bear Stearns in 2008. he was rightfully
reamed for all of that even though it
could be considered that like well you
know did he have all the information
maybe not but he's a financial advisor
he does this for a living if you go on
and you make a big call and you turn out
to be wrong and people lose tons of
money
you are going to take a hit I think
rightfully so but no I don't think these
people should go to jail or anything
like that like oh it's such a
complicated thing I mean I just feel it
personally myself I get it but you still
feel the burden of the fact that you're
opinion has influence I know it
shouldn't I know Tom Brady's opinion on
financial investments should not
influence but it does right that's just
the reality of it right that's a real
burden I didn't know anything about SPF
or FTX it wasn't on my radar at all
um but I could see myself like taking
them on as a sponsor I've seen a lot of
people I respect uh Sam Harris and
others like talk talk with SPF uh like
he's doing good for the world so I could
see myself being Hoodwinked having not
done research and the same thing makes
me wonder
like I I don't want to become cynical
and uh but it makes you wonder who are
the people in your life you trust that
are like that could be the next SPF or
or Worse big powerful leaders Hitler and
all that kind of stuff
um
to what degree do you want to
investigate do you want to uh hold their
feet to the fire see through their
[ __ ] call them on their [ __ ] and
also as a friend if you happen to be
friends or have a connection how to help
them not slip into the land of fraud I
don't know all of that is just
overwhelming yeah I mean I mean we
should be clear like Finance is sort of
a special space
where
you're talking about people's money
you're not talking about whether people
someone takes a bad supplement or like a
supplement that is just they're fifty
dollars out right
I think the scale of harm yeah and
therefore responsibility escalates
depending on what field you're in just
like I wouldn't hold Tom Brady as like
if he gives a bad football opinion right
and he should have known better that is
a different scale of harm than a doctor
giving bad advice right like life's it
like he tells you a pill works and the
pill kills you or something like that
there's just different levels of
accountability depending on the field
you're in and you have to be aware of it
Finance is an extra you have to be
extremely conservative if you're going
to give Financial advice because you're
playing with people's lives and you
cannot play with them haphazardly you
cannot gamble with them you cannot play
with them on a bet because you're
getting paid a lot of money
it's just the nature of the space and so
with the with the space comes the
responsibility and the accountability
and I don't think you can get around
that who was uh Dan Friedberg that you
mentioned some of these figures in the
SBF around that are interesting to you
super interesting kind of subject
because Dan Friedberg is uh the former
general counsel for ultimate bet
ultimate bet is a was a poker site where
famously they got in a scandal because
uh the owner Russ Hamilton was cheating
with a little software piece of code
they called God Mode God mode allowed
you to see up the guy across from you's
hand obviously you can imagine you can
win pretty consistently if you know
exactly what your opponent has very
unethical
they I should be clear that for some
inexplicable reason I don't think they
were ever charged and convicted of a
crime but they were investigated by a
gambling commission that found they made
tens of millions of dollars this way for
sure
and
Dan Friedberg is the general counsel
he's caught on a call basically
conspiring with Russ to hide this fraud
he's saying we should blame it on a cons
you know a consultant third party and
Russ Hamilton famously says you know
like it was me I did it I don't want to
give the money back
find basically a way to get rid of this
so that's Dan friedberg's big
achievement like that's what he's known
for he's most known for and this is the
guy they pick as their Chief regulatory
officer for FTX why do you hire somebody
who I I get it the not formally charged
and convicted investigated there's all
the and there's tape out there so I want
to be clear about what's actually
available evidence
but someone who's seemingly owned a
cheat only achievement is hiding fraud
why do you hire that guy if the
intention is not to hide is not to hide
fraud so this is a question I put to you
know Sam bankman freed and his answer
was
well we have a lot of lawyers well and I
said well it's your Chief regulatory
officer he's like well it wasn't we we
did regulate a lot and it was just this
big dance of you know basically he's
done great work he's a great guy and
I think that tells you everything you
need to know and there's figures like
that probably even at the lower levels
like just infiltrate the entire
organization well it's just like why
yeah why wasn't there a CFA why why
wasn't there anyone in that space who
could seemingly
be the eyes that goes holy whatever we
need to we we're in dangerous territory
here right
um so yeah it seems very deliberate I
mean I talked to one FTX employee that
they talked about who's told me they
talked about
taking I think it was taking FTX US
public and Sam was very against the idea
and the employee in retrospect
speculated that it might have been
because you'd face so much scrutiny like
regulation-wise like you'd have to you
know go through a lot like more thorough
audits all that kind of stuff that
basically he knew they would never pass
um so yeah I mean it's it's red flags
all the way down with that guy
and you hope all of them get punished
everyone who knew I mean I think for
sure there are people at FTX who didn't
know I think there are some people at
Alameda who didn't know
oh wait there's degrees sorry to
interrupt but there's degrees of not
knowing yes there's a looking away when
you kind of know yeah Shady stuff that's
still the same as knowing right that's
might be even worse yeah like I was
talking to one Insider and we were
talking about the insider trading they
were telling me about this insider
trading and
I said do you think this was Criminal
and they said it was probably criminal
in hindsight yes
and the question is someone who answers
a question like that what does that like
mean you know like it was probably so
you're right there there are different
degrees I mean I'll say at the most
basic I would be very happy if everyone
who had Direct knowledge went to jail
which I don't think will happen to be
clear I think a lot of people are going
to cut deals prosecutors are going to
cut deals so they actually nail
sambangman freed I think that's their
only focus what about his reputation
what do you think about all these
interviews
um do you think they are helping him do
you think they're good for the world do
you think they're bad for the world like
what's your sense and like say you get
to sit down interview with him for three
hours
and I'm holding the door closed what uh
what kind of is that a useful
conversation or not or at this point it
should be legal
and that's it I think it's useful I mean
I think with resp it's all it's all
about how you interview them you can
interview someone responsibly you can
interview him irresponsibly I think
we've seen examples of both what's in
irresponsible I keep interrupting you
rudely that's okay no no unacceptable no
no I think it's fine
um there was like a New York Times
interview which
spends an amount of time any amount of
time talking about his sleep and he's
like yeah I'm sleeping great I mean I
think that's so deeply disrespectful to
the victims and especially when you're
you're not even releasing an interview
live it's like you have time to triage
what you're going to talk about why
would you spend any amount of time
talking about the sleep that a fraudster
is get get it's just so weird and well
let's do it can I steal man in that case
I don't I don't I don't think it turned
out I think that's I think that's I I
think okay here's the thing
I could see myself talking about
somebody's sleep or getting in
somebody's mind if I knew I have
unlimited time with them if I knew I had
like a four hours because you get into
the minds of the person how they think
how they see the world because I think
that ultimately reveals
if they're actually really good at lying
it reveals the depths the complexity of
the mind that through like osmosis you
get to understand like this person this
person is not as trivial as you realize
also makes you maybe realize that this
person is has a lot of Hope has a lot of
positive ambition that's like uh that
has developed over their life and then
certain interesting ways things went
wrong yeah it become corrupt and all
that kind of stuff you just that's all
fine but this was this conversation was
not properly contextualized yes in the
world of what he did
it and I you know I've I've asked about
this interview because I was like so
curious it was out of the New York Times
and there was not much mention of fraud
or jail or the the big crimes like
misappropriation of even client assets
it was just sort of this you know Sam
sat down with me he's he's under
investigation but there's not much
specifics and then it's like yeah he's
playing storybook brawl he's sleeping
he's and it's just like okay this isn't
adding to the conversation especially in
the New York Times it's like uh you
should be grilling right right exactly
so
um but as I said I mean it's all range
the gamut and some interviews like some
of it's okay and then some of it's weird
like the Andrew Sorkin interview he
asked some hard-hitting questions which
I really appreciated and then at the end
he goes ladies and gentlemen Sam begman
freed and everyone gives like a like an
ovation for
Sam I mean the Steel Man of that of
course is like they're actually
applauding Andrew Sorkin but the way you
like lay it up I wouldn't go like ladies
and gentlemen it's like an Applause line
it's like ladies and gentlemen the
Eagles Elton John Lex Friedman and so to
go to so you have this like deal book
Summit where you have all these
important figures that are positively
important and at the end you have Sam
bankman free to fraudster and yo ladies
and gentlemen Sam Beekman freed
everyone's applauding that I think is a
net like I think that's a negative I
think the way that the Optics of that
just were all wrong and so I think um
yeah you have to be very responsible
I think it's useful going back to how
you can usefully do this
you can even when somebody's determined
to lie to you
It's always important to
pin them down to a an accounting of
events because that is unimaginably
helpful when it comes to a prosecutor
trying to prove this guy's guilty is
if you say you didn't do a crime but you
don't tell me any details about it
day of the trial you can basically make
up any story right but if you tell me in
detail where you were that day I can go
hunt down you say you were with Joe I go
hunt down Joe and he says he wasn't with
you boom you've lost credibility and now
you're much more you're much more likely
to be convicted so it's really important
to get sbf's exact accounting of how
things went wrong because right now he's
positioning himself to throw his uh
Alameda CEO Caroline Ellison under the
bus like she did everything she knew
everything I knew nothing
well as Caroline Ellison's going to take
the stand and go well I have all these
text messages and this is all a lie and
then Sam begman freed is going to be
completely
you know
uh ruined like self-ruin by his own
design so I think it's more like a legal
type of uh like get the details of where
he was what he was thinking what the I
think it's like yeah I think it's
it's public probably cares to get to
know what happened to and again I think
if you're if you're careful
you can expose someone for as they lie
to you without giving in to those lies
right like without capitulating to oh
I'm just going to assume you're correct
I think you can point to well Lex you
say it happened this way but you've lied
about X Y and Z why should we believe
you that's a suddenly a totally
different conversation than just being
like Oh okay that's how it happened the
thing I caught that bothered me
and the thing I hope to do in interviews
of
um if if I eventually get good at this
thing is the human aspect of it which is
like which I think you have to do in
person
is he seems a bit nonchalant about the
pain and the suffering of people
that I have red flags about in the way
he's he communicates about the loss of
money like the pain that people are
feeling about the money I get red flags
like you're not uh forget if you're
involved in that pain or not you're not
feeling that pain
well he'll he'll say he is but he'll be
playing a game of League of Legends
while doing it no but I just see it from
his face I know and that needs to be
grilled yeah like that little human
dance there that's I mean I
um I considered
I talked to him I considered doing an
in-person interview with him
um
and you know are you still considering
it
I don't know do you think do you think I
I should in person I think it depends if
you think you have anything to add to
the conversation a lot of people have
yeah there's been already you did an
incredible job thanks
I think I I think I would like to grill
the [ __ ] out of them as a fellow human
yeah but not investigating yeah yeah
like like another human being another
human being who I can have compassion
for who has caused a lot of suffering in
the world
like that that grilling like basically
convey the anger that people and the
pain that people are feeling
right like that yeah
I think
I think it'd be really hard I mean like
that guy is sort of a master dancer and
what he would say at the end of it
because I've listened to so many
interviews of him
um I probably am like a GPT model for
Sam
I think he would do some kind of thing
about like yeah I really um I really um
hear you and um you know it's it's just
terrible I feel such an obligation to
the people who've lost money and you
know it's just it's a lot of money it's
a lot of money you know you do something
like that and it would be very
superficially like okay
but when you gr when you drill down to
the details of what he did it's just
impossible that he didn't know and one
of the things that I wish I had asked
maybe I can talk about like I wish I had
gone on this it's just so hard when
you're doing a live interview to kind of
focus on one thing
everyone's asked about the terms of
service so in the terms of service there
was like
we can't touch your funds your funds are
safe we're never going to do anything
with that anytime anyone brings that up
he says oh well there's this other term
disservice over here with margin trading
accounts remember we talked about it's a
derivatives platform if you're in our
derivative side
you have you're subject to different
terms of service which kind of lets us
like move your money around with
everyone else okay
so we treat it as one big pool of funds
and that's sort of the explanation of
how this all happened is we had this
huge leverage position and we lost
everything
but what no one has sort of done a good
enough job getting to the heart of is
that this pool of funds never was
segregated properly it was all treated
under the same umbrella of we can use
your funds there was no amount of we
have the client deposits which were just
deposited with us and not like used to
margin trade or do anything over here
These funds over here we have saved they
didn't fundamentally they lied from the
get-go about how they were treating the
most precious assets which is your
customer deposits that you said you
didn't invest clearly you put them all
over here you YOLO gambled them and then
when everyone starts withdrawing from
here they don't have any money over here
so that is like one of the most
fundamental things that I haven't seen
anyone Grill him on and uh the next time
if I get the chance to Ambush them again
that's that's what I'm going to drill
down on because it's impossible for that
not to be fraud
there's no world where you had a pool of
funds over here and now you don't have
them without you somehow borrowing over
here because if you deposited one
Bitcoin and I never sold that Bitcoin
and it's earmarked Lex Friedman and you
come and it's not there something had to
happen right well it says this is so
interesting so for me
the approach that like you said the most
important question of uh because for you
it's like were those funds segregated
for me the question is as a human being
how would you feel if you're observing
that so like
you know that like marshmallow test with
the babies like it's the human thing
it's a human nature question like uh I
can understand there's a pile of money
and you uh
the good faith interpretation is like
well I know what to do with that pile of
money to grow that pile of money let me
just take a little bit of that
like how willing are you to do that kind
of thing how able are you to do that
kind of thing and when [ __ ] goes wrong
what goes through your mind how does it
become corrupted how do you begin to
Lose Yourself how do you uh delegate
responsibility for the failures like as
opposed to getting facts
try to sneak into the human Mind of a
person when they're thinking that
because the facts there's they're start
gonna start waffling they're gonna start
like trying to make sure they don't say
anything that gets them incriminated
right but I just I want to understand
the human being there because I think
that indirectly gives you a sense of
where were you in this big picture I
think I've talked to so many people who
have sort of committed some range of
like outright fraud to like misleading
marketing
no one thinks they're a bad person
nobody admits that they did it and they
knew they are almost nobody does there's
actually one funny exception but um
you had a guy who admitted like yeah I
did it it was wrong and uh you know but
I did it and I wanted the money which
was kind of like almost refreshing in
its honesty but um the reason I focus on
like the facts is because
unless you find a bright red line
humans can rationalize anything I can
rationalize any level of like well I did
this because I had the best of
intentions and if you play the intention
game you'll never convict anyone because
everyone has good intentions everyone's
honest everyone's doing the best they
can and got misleaded and got misguided
ultimately you have to drill down to the
concrete and go look
I get it you're just like the last 50
guys that I interviewed you had the best
of intentions it all went wrong I'm very
sorry for you but at the end of the day
there's people hurting and there's
people that have significant damage to
their life because of you what did you
actually do and what can we prove taking
intention out of it taking motivation
out what can we prove that you did that
was unethical illegal or immoral and
like that is
sort of what usually I try to go to
because I will do those human interviews
but
um you know it's just like it's just
it's like the same record on repeat I
mean a lot I got it the same I I'm with
you I'm with you on the everything you
said but there is ways to do
to avoid the record and repeat I mean
those are different skill set you're
exceptionally good at the investigative
like investigating I do believe there's
a way to break through the the repeat
there's the different techniques to it
yeah one of which is like taking outside
of their particular story yes EV when
everyone looks at their own story they
can see themselves as a good player
doing good but you can do other thought
experiments I mean there's uh but
they'll follow you they'll know what the
thought experiment is no well it depends
it depends my friend I mean the like uh
you know to me there's a million of them
but of just exploring your ethics would
you kill somebody to protect your family
and you explore that you start to sneak
into like what's your sense uh of the
in-group versus the owl group how much
damage you can do to the out group and
who is the out group and you start to
build that sense of the person are we
like the two Mobsters that we're dressed
as do we protect the family and [ __ ]
everyone else you're with us and the
ones who are against us [ __ ] them or do
we have a sense that human human all
human beings are all have value equal
value we want to wear a join Humanity
there's ways to get to that and you
start to build up this sense of like
some people that make a lot of money are
better than others they deserve to be at
the Top If you have that feeling you
start to get get a sense of like yeah
the poor people are the dumb asses
they're the idiots if you believe that
then you start to understand that this
person may have been at the core of this
whole corrupt organization to yes two
things one
I think you should join me on this side
of the table we'll put SPF over here
yeah well good guy bad guy human facts
like you're the bad guy I'm like no no
slow down coffee what is your feeling
about Humanity
yeah have you been getting enough sleep
yeah right obviously so I so I think no
I think there's a lot of Truth to what
you said
one thing I've noticed that is hard to
combat is sort of like preference
falsification and just like just the
outright lying about those things is
tough to kind of pin down but yeah
you're absolutely right there's ways to
interview people there's all sorts of
interesting techniques and yeah I don't
disagree good good cop bad cop we should
do this should be like a sitcom okay